стріляли не пам'ятають нас чи від них чи
вони до нас
кинувся наш будинок світло відключили тепло
ну воду так далі але так ми поїхали
тому що він дуже голосно неспокійно
смілива така дівчина шкода їх вчора вони
звичайно плакали сьогодні вже більш-менш
так не хочуть їх з батьками, бо
як же ми батьки залишаються ми їли їсти
маленькі чотири з половиною мене у
найменшому хлопчику самому
старшому 17 років, що їм потрібно в цьому
мені здається зараз їм треба одне
це тепло як би підтримка найголовніша
підтримка яку він спробуємо його та й
дати
і
після приїзду людей за дівки у нас був
вже п'ятиденний запас протягом
сьогодні ми під'їжджали приватні особи фонди
які підвозили нам продукти харчування
хочуть порядком на 10 днів це точно
стабільно